I believe you said in an interview with
NYU that you can't stand a lazy student
right what do you see in most
independent filmmakers however old they
are
that makes them lazy and that hinders
their career
well I don't want to make a blanket
statements about independent filmmakers
but I've had students who are lazy and
laziness is something I really can't
tolerate so because of laziness I think
that that speaks of a sense of
entitlement and that's just not a good
look in this industry where you think
that you are title to something that you
didn't you deserve is something because
you're wherever you think you are
it doesn't work like that another thing
I'd like to add is that and I'm speaking
about my school a lot of people come on
in why you taking it because you have
this degree from the station's
prestigious institution in Y E or USC or
AFI Columbia in the real world then
really give a you know if you don't
have the talent that three doesn't mean
a thing when you come out of school you
should have your directorship the film
your deep you should have a real edits
you have a real if your screen right you
have scripts so people and people really
want to see the work you have done
you